One of the big surprises of the whole periodic video project for
me was my actually seeing a sample of technetium
before I tell you how I saw it, let me explain why I was surprised.
Technetium was one of four elements that were predicted by
Mendeleev to exist in the periodic table, but had not yet been discovered.
He predicted it first to have an atomic weight of a hundred,
which he then revised to 99, which was pretty accurate.
So take Newseum is element 43 and obviously between
molybdenum, which is 42 and routine, which is 44,
the real discovery came when two Italians,
Emilio segregate and color Perrier in Palermo in Sicily was
sent a sample of molybdenum that had been irradiated
in the cyclotron in Berkeley.
It had been irradiated with a mixture of neutrons and due to runs due to
rums are the nucleus of deuterium, one proton,
one neutron.
And so cigarette and period were desolving up this piece of
molybdenum, which was highly radioactive. So they let it sit for a bit.
So some of the radioactivity decade,
just to find what was in it by carefully precipitating and
seeing where the radioactivity went,
they isolated the first sample of technetium,
but it was too small to see,
but by its behavior and the fact that it precipitated together with rhenium,
they could tell that it must be in the same group.
I think it was just sent to them because they were interested.
Nobody thought expected, take new, seem to be in it.
And the technetium was there for the first element that had
ever been made. Synthetically chemists,
who were looking at the structure of the periodic table,
felt that synthetic elements were somehow cheating.
So it should not be put on the periodic table.
Can you imagine that the paper was published in 1937 and
nothing happened to the second world war.
Then in the second world war, there was the Manhattan project,
the development of nuclear weapons and lots of new synthetic
elements were discovered, particularly plutonium,
which had never been discovered before and after the war,
1947, very shortly before I was born,
there was a historic paper was published in the journal nature by the
German chemist Paneth who during Nazi times had moved to the UK
and was working at the university of Durham. He laid down the ground rules,
which exist to this day for the naming of elements.
Number one,
the right to name an should go to the first presumably group or
person to give definite proof of the existence of one of its
isotopes. Second point in deciding the priority of the discovery.
There should be no discrimination between naturally occurring,
an artificially produced isotopes. And the third point,
and this is very important.
If a claim to such a discovery has been accepted in the past,
but is refuted. That means contradicted by later research,
the names should be deleted and replaced by one chosen by the real discoverer.
And those rules applied to this day.
And it was technetium that really precipitated this.
So what happened then was that the names of six new
elements,
including plutonium were accepted and cigarette and period were
invited to name their elements and they chose the name
technetium in the same journal in a really short paper from the
Greek word, which means synthetic.
So it is embodied in his name that it was the first synthetic
element in the early 1960s with improvement of instrumentation.
People discovered that in uranium minerals,
because of the radioactive decay of uranium, you can detect tiny,
tiny traces of technetium and
therefore it is natural after all.
So the name isn't quite right. And then in 1972,
there was an extraordinary discovery by geologists in Gabon,
in Africa,
where they discovered that in a uranium deposits underground
about a million years ago, a natural nuclear reactor had started.
There was a high enough concentration of uranium for nuclear reaction to take
place. And because of this nuclear reaction,
there were in fact traces of technetium found under the ground because of
all the nuclear research that was done during the Manhattan project,
there was an abundant supply of technetium became available after the
second world war and people started stunting the chemistry and you can get a
wide range of compounds. And as you might expect,
the chemistry is perhaps a little closer to rhenium than to
manganese because heavier elements tend to be more similar.
But one of the most interesting applications turns out to be in medicine.
The application is in diagnosis.
When people have cancer,
it's often quite hard to see the tumors or particularly the secondary
tumors that spread across somebody's body because they're small and they are not
easily imaged,
but turns out that if you take radioactive molybdenum,
molybdenum 99,
it decays by emission of electrons to make
technetium,
but very unusually and something which we've never talked about before the
technetium is formed with the nucleus in an excited
state that is with higher energy than it might have otherwise in this excited
state is symbolized by the letter M which stands for meta
stable, which means it's stable for a short time, but not very long.
And so what happens is this matter staple,
technetium decays to the stable isotope or stable
state, but with the same mass and gives out a gamma Ray,
which can penetrate a large distance through, for example, human flesh,
and then much more slowly, the take new SIM 99 decay is to routine Liam.
So what happens is that if you do your chemistry very quickly,
you can isolate this technetium 99
M and before it decays,
you can react it with another chemical,
which will complex that's bind round the technetium and you
choose this, um,
binding chemical so that it will also bind to tumor cells
selectively. It will bind to the tumor and not to ordinary organs.
So quickly you inject it into the patients.
It goes round the body and is localized at the tumors.
Then if you put the patient into a suitable detector or
array of detectors, you can measure the gamma rays coming out,
and the gamma rays will come out much more strongly from where the tumors are.
And because the techniques simply case rapidly,
you can get a good signal to do your imaging without
giving the patient a big overall dose of radioactivity.
So now this brings me back to how I saw technetium.
Some years ago,
I went to zero at university and met a professor,
Roger Alberto who's one of the world's experts in techniques in
chemistry. During the coffee break,
Roger came up to me and pulled out of his pocket,
a little metal vile and unscrewed the lid and took out
a glass container.
And inside was a piece of metal coated with techniques.
I was amazed. I never thought I would be able to see this.
So I immediately asked him how he could get hold of this stuff.
And she explained that one of his coworkers had used electrolysis
that's parsing electric,
current through a solution to deposit a thin layer
of technetium onto a piece of copper.
Now you don't need very much metal,
only a few nanometers to see what the metal looks like,
because light doesn't go through it. And in fact, this particular sample,
I think had probably a couple of milligrams of technetium on it.
So it looked just the same as a large block of techniques and would look,
but I felt really excited because here was an element which
I'd seen sort of in brackets on the periodic table.
And I never thought I would actually hold a sample in my hand,
or I held the glass bottle and because take Newseum decays
by beater emission, that's emitting electrons.
And these electrons don't penetrate through material very easily,
even as small glass file is quite enough to protect people,
at least for a short time. So I could safely hold it.
And in triumph,
I held it against my tie next to the symbol of technetium and
I felt I'd really made the discovery.
There. Thanks for watching this video. Of course,
we have made videos on every element on the periodic table on the screen right
now I will put links to a playlist so you can watch well,
all hundred and 18 in order, if you want. Some of them are quite old,
but we are updating them with new videos all the time,
like this one to make bigger and better videos about each element.
And you can support the process as well on Patrion. And if you do that,
there's a chance for you to adopt an element on our periodic videos webpage,
and you can have your name there under that particular element,
check it out at patrion.com/periodic videos. But as always,
the best thing you can do is keep watching here on YouTube,
stay subscribed to the channel, switch on the notifications. So, you know,
every time we upload a new video and we'll see you again.
Very soon,